Sabina a difficult tournament for you up
to this point but finally you get that
breakout Victory how do you feel right
now
in one game you know it's yesterday's
been a tough day for for me
um realizing what happened to elshon and
I just couldn't play and then I saw so
much I felt like it was hatred coming
towards him and I'm quite emotional as a
person so I just did something about it
I did I did on Instagram yeah I I felt
like he it can happen to anyone to just
plunder out of the opening and I just
felt really bad because you know it
happened to him and of course you know
we're so close and
um I was just you know very mad at
everyone and of course mad at myself
because I felt that although I haven't
really scored many points I feel that
overall my play was pretty decent I mean
maybe I would have some bad
positions out of the opening let's say
but I was able to come back in a lot of
the games but the results of course of
course don't show and typically I like
to
to inspire other people that's something
that I've always wanted and then
um showing people that you should never
give up it doesn't matter how bad your
tournament is going you should just keep
fighting I think that's something that I
want everyone to to kind of see and
believe in themselves and just is a
tough game but
um
you should never give up you should
always fight so and I think he also
mentioned this on one of your posts on
social media and you mentioned your
sponsor as well for this tournament
would you like to give a shout out to
your sponsor thanks for that yeah so um
I think it's really nice when you have
students that care about you not just
they don't just take lessons with you
because
you know they they like you or they
think you can help them but they also
are inspired by you and
um
Steve is actually one of elshon students
and he was very nice to
um to support us during this tournament
so I I'm just very thankful for him I've
been wearing all the gear I actually
have it underneath this shirt
take us through today's game because it
was indeed a very tense battle it was
like yeah so
it was a minute decision actually I did
sure what um
she would play I know she's your student
so I know you sometimes play the
groomfield and I was like okay maybe
she'll play this but in the tournament
she didn't really play it and then
literally last minute I remember that I
played some H4 in a game three four
years ago was this before the round
before before of course before the round
yeah yeah I I looked a little bit and I
was like okay what do I do and actually
I had no idea what I would go for and
then I was like okay let's just go H4
and see what happens at H5 I don't think
is the best I don't think it's the very
good choice
what is this movie but of course the
position whatever you play on H5 is not
like losing yeah of course nature I mean
the idea is to kind of try to drag the
Knight away taking G6 and but white
doesn't really have any attack so I I I
was happy when she played H5 and you
know I have the tendency sometimes when
I don't have a good tournament to just
start throwing my pieces out and I told
myself I will not I will not do that so
I try to play as positional as possible
just develop my pieces I think
um yeah I missed this idea with A4 of
hers I thought I would have Queen B3 and
I would be fine and then she played day
four and yeah
oh B4 I could have played or B3 yeah B3
yeah also makes a lot of sense uh yeah
so here
I was trying to find a way to improve
the position because I think white is a
little bit better with the center and
black is struggling to play C5 or E5 and
that's usually what you want to do so
yeah I don't know if I played the best
but I like Knight D5 and then I thought
she had to take and here you're still
maintaining yeah the balance yeah and
then here I took with the queen you know
I thought sometime I thought
I should take with the pawn that's
normal and then go to K1 and trade
pieces very good D1 or something that's
what I thought but then I was like no no
Queen B3 looks nice because she cannot
take any four because G6 is hanging and
yeah good position and
she played this move uh King to H7
getting yes of this diagonal of course
yeah Knight C3 I think it was good she
played all the moves that I thought she
would play and then even like I thought
Queen 8 and queen A7 and here I couldn't
come up with a plan because she does
want some Knight A4
I thought
and then try to trade them three as well
yeah okay three first Knight A4 try to
trade the knight uh
yeah so if I go back to F3 basically I
let the C4 square right yeah
so I was like okay what have I done I
need to do something on the other side
so that's why I went F4 and oh it was
bad okay great apparently this is
getting some problems F6 I think she
just didn't realize that she weakened Z6
the E6 Square yeah so once I went back I
think Knight C4 has to be played
Knight to C4 or 283 still to be the best
Queen E6 Queen to E6
um I think F5 but this is already yeah
it's very messy yeah very computer-ish
right and she played this move Knight to
A4
yeah trade and 95 I thought was a
mistake because of course I have Rook C5
and suddenly I have F5 which is gorgeous
perhaps this is what she missed through
yeah I think so I think she probably
missed that
uh what were you what was the move I
thought she was she would take uh in A2
and then I still wanted to take yeah and
I thought you had to come somehow with
the queen to trade with Queen B8 but so
maybe Queen 25 attack and then and still
proxy five right something like this to
see five the same thing yeah 8. try to
do things of this nature
but still the position remained
complicated and she made this big
mistake with Knight to B5 root to C5
yeah and then she went back she probably
realized that it's not looking very good
oh F5 was why did she not take on A2 at
this point F5 F5 yeah I thought it's
yeah her King side gets shattered yeah
very nice I was yeah I was quite
confident with my rook in C5 and I knew
ideas would be six would not work
because she dropped C6
and um
yeah going into this I panicked here at
some point I guess I haven't played the
best we were both getting really low in
time and she had yeah she had some ideas
some very aggressive ideas I hope I
didn't miss a mate or something at this
point things got really messy right and
you actually found this key move King to
F3 to defend the position you know I've
lost uh against Jennifer you I had
pretty I thought I saved it after the
time travel and then there was some kind
of idea with two Rooks mating me and I
was like okay I will not get mated
that's the point so you're getting
flashbacks from I I was yeah the tough
thing I think it's very hard to do when
you're playing a tournament because
especially as long as this one because
you always have these memories in your
head what are you gonna do and yeah so
but she played this move Knight twitch
yeah I thought after that it's just
should be totally lost managed to paint
the night and convert it nicely yeah
Sabina congratulations big victory for
you to what are you going to do to
tonight to celebrate I'm just going to
call my the two people actually have
been three people supporting me today
and I'm just gonna call them immediately
and just be thankful for for believing
in me and then of course just uh you
know it's just a game I have to to keep
playing tomorrow still plenty of rounds
to go five rounds yeah
Sabina congratulations we'll see you
tomorrow thanks
our congratulations as well